winning an Oscar is it's great honor and
so this is a wonderful feeling anything
yeah that's all good but there are
certain weird things that come along
with a bit of baggage for example I I
recently received a summons to appear at
it's very secretive or safe house that
the Academy keeps welcome 1989 Academy
Award winner Kevin Kline thank you I am
sir Cecil Worthington sir Cecil sucesso
I see did you bring him Oscar oh yes I
brought him come we have much to discuss
my name is sir Cecil Worthington though
never officially knighted I've been
entrusted by the Academy to teach the
proper care and etiquette of this Oscar
statuette mr. Klein we have photographic
evidence that you've been miss handling
your Academy Award what from where TMZ
TMZ if you must because of this the
Academy has deemed it necessary that you
take a refresher course on the proper
care and maintenance of this statuette
that we lovingly call
I really don't have time today shop ah
you're free to go mr. Klein but until
you take this course
Oscar must stay you're telling me that
unless I submit to this refresher course
you're gonna keep my Oscar
what a brilliant recap of the premise he
needs some remedial work and by god he's
going to get it then the rules and I
ain't gonna change him what is the right
way to hold an Oscar there's a right way
to hold an awesome it's a right way
Nahal the mouseka yes there is a right
way to hold the Oscar and it is as such
left hand under the base right hand on
the statuette below the knees Oscar does
like a banana split but not with crushed
he has a good rule of thumb keep the
thumb below the bum keep the thumb below
the bum again keep the thumb below the
bum again again thumb I call it the rule
of bum
I think the Oscar is bigger than the
cinema personally I've never seen a
movie I don't believe in them you must
not how is it made
how is it unmade how is it distributed
how is it stolen
pop quiz how much does an Oscar weigh
how much doesn't Oscar way I know how
much doesn't ask 0.5 pounds
yes mr. Tai getting the knife box you
two shot to live here's a snicker it's
fun-sized yes I've been told I look like
Oscar except I think Oscar has a nicer
bottom than I do
it's got a nice shelf on it you could
put in the bats blue on it stay there
for years how was it earned how is it
how is it how is it are you listening to
me ah yes very good now
the ceremony is over you've brought
Oscar home where do you place your Oscar
you know this it's a simple mnemonic
device we've been over this every
village enters Knight soaring upwards
Ravens flight adventure commotion
deletion yes on an even surface and
Oscar is placed on an even surface I
think all ready for another Snickers no
for the pinning ceremony
yeah yeah that's really it means oh
don't touch it I shouldn't say that I
have a favorite student
but I'm Kevin inclined to oh I thank you
Thank You mr. Klein yes I believe this
is yours
careful bye
who's next sure good god